I'm here to pass on some travel tips that will help make your next trip a lot easier.
Let's begin with what to do before you head to the airport.
Here's a phrase that will save you time: online check-in.
Many airlines now allow you to check in on your computer at home up to 24 hours in advance.
You can even print your boarding pass at home...
...so when you arrive at the airport, you're ready for takeoff.
Now, for what to bring.
Be a strategic packer.
That too will get you through the airport faster.
If you are not planning on checking your suitcase, pack it carefully.
There are strict regulations when it comes to what is an acceptable carry-on item.
Think before you pack liquids and gels,...
...including makeup like liquid eyeliners, lip gloss, foundation and perfumes.
Whether you plan on checking luggage or not,...
...do yourself a favor and bring a carry-on containing your essential items...
...like medication, eyeglasses, expensive jewelry and maybe even a change of clothes.
You never know if your luggage will land when you do.
Having some must-haves on you may save the day and your vacation.
And make sure you have identification on the luggage you do check.
It's a foolproof way to be sure you're grabbing your own suitcase.
And it ensures a way for others to get in touch with you...
...should you and your luggage get separated.